I can see the world though, in the future,
where I'm not missing out on those opportunities.
So that's my vision for this world.
My vision is to be able to have incidental
learning experiences.
The point is and the key is access.
For everyone here today.
So this is a deaf instructor who is in our
College of Liberal Arts.
He's teaching psychology.
He's teaching a course here on the neurobiology
of schizophrenia.
And what we'll do during the question session
at the end of the talk,
I would ask that you ask your questions through
your device.
So that what happens is in the question mode
it will actually show who is asking the question.
And show a transcript of your question on
the screen.
We learned a lot about the classroom experience
and the learning experience.
In college, social life is very important
as well.
Do you have studies that show that technology
can promote in terms of the deaf and hearing
students
talking with each other or communicating with
each other?
If you mean communicating through technology,
it hasn't been done yet.
I just wrote about it in a chapter that just
went to press.
One of the issues for deaf kids, even the
ones who are now using spoken language and
implants
is that, in elementary school there aren't
too many issues
except that the deaf kids who have the best
hearing and speech
are the ones most accepted by the hearing
kids.